avec valérie pécresse fait le choix
d'une agriculture fier compétitive
durable et qui rayonne dans le monde
pour que le travail de les agriculteurs
paient enfin nous augmenterons
immédiatement le revenu des agriculteurs
en baissant d'un tiers les cotisations
vieillesse nous améliorons la
compétitivité des exploitations en
baissant le niveau de taxe foncière sur
le non bâti nous pérenniserons
l'allègement des charges patronales todt
pour les employeurs de travailleurs
saisonniers nous exonérons des charges
patronales les petites exploitations qui
prennent un jeune en apprentissage ou
garantiront la solidarité de l'état en
couvrant le reste à charge que subissent
les filières lors des crises climatiques
et sanitaires nous allons accroître le
recours aux produits locaux dans la
restauration scolaire hospitalière et
administratives avec valérie pécresse
nous allons aussi préparer le
renouvellement des générations en
supprimant la taxation sur les plus
values lors de cessions d'exploitation à
un jeune agriculteur en créant un
complément de retraite aux agriculteurs
qui font le choix de transmettre leur
exploitation un jeune nous ne
permettrons plus aucune retraite
d'agriculteur inférieur au smic et nous
allégerons la fiscalité des
transmissions pour un héritier en ligne
directe
[Musique]